but let's talk about this first story
it's a friday night everybody and we're
going to make sure that you're getting
only the best of entertainment
hi brown we were like should we talk
about joe biden
and the nuclear code very serious
and then luke was like we got to talk
about the chinese
shoving stuff up u.s diplomats butts and
i said
i don't know if it's the most important
story in the world but it's certainly
entertaining well we were talking about
the story i mean i came in here i was
like do you guys believe this is
happening and i went off on a tangent i
was very uh
elaborative about it and and you thought
this was a joke yeah
i was like i was like man this guy in
his metaphors this is fantastic i
know it's it's hitting it's gripping i'm
like i wonder what they're doing
that's happening yeah what was this
mainstream media news
us official asks china to not subject
their staff to kovid
behind probes that go inside of you and
of course the chinese response was very
telling at first they were like no no
this never happened i don't know what
you guys were talking about they denied
it
now they're saying oh this was done in
error and we promised
it won't be ever done again so here's
here's what happened the state
department's pissed
all right we have the story from the
hill state department says it never
agreed to china giving us diplomats
coveted 19
anal tests they say chinese officials
who
forced they forced american diplomats to
undergo
bum-bum swabs for covet-19 did so in
error
the state department told the hill on
thursday as beijing denies it conducted
the tests at all
the washington post reported last week
that u.s officials
had said some american personnel in
china complained that they were being
subjected to anal swab tests for
coronavirus by chinese authorities
this is so obvious what they're doing
they're doing this to subjugate and
humiliate
what they're doing makes no sense
they're going to clone well it depends
uh with what dna from no no no no no dna
from the butt
yeah i think it's part of that i think
no no no
no no ian is on to something yeah you're
right because there was official us
government sources coming out just a few
days ago talking about how china was
trying to get the covid tests that were
used
in order to get dna samples from
americans
so they could better predictively
predict the market and dominate it in
the pharma industrial complex game
yes i'm not kidding you so china now is
on this huge rampage of them trying to
get as much information as they can
they understand information is the new
oil they've been
on this huge race trying to get as much
as they can because they know hey
if we get everyone's dna we're going to
know what they're going to get sick of
in the future that we're going to know
what ailments they're going to have
we're going to know what pills to make
what medicine to make to sell it back to
the united states at a cheaper profit
that we're going to mass-produce
and we're going to out-compete the other
competitors in this larger pharma
industrial complex so this was a legit
thing that they're talking about
and there's a reason politicians bring
their own toilets when they visit other
countries
the information you could get from your
you know what uh
is it extremely important and and many
politicians
literally i mean there's there's reasons
secret service literally has a detail
uh probably ones with the bad political
opinions but the secret service has a
detail
that that is in charge of collecting the
president's poop to make sure a foreign
country doesn't get it
because if they do they'll yes yep
that's i'm telling you so this is this
is this is more than just
ridicule in my opinion it wouldn't
surprise me if these larger
uh butt probes were done in a way to get
the dna of us diplomats in
in some kind of larger uh information
grab that of course the chinese will use
to their advantage in their fifth
generational warfare
larger propaganda efforts that they're
in charge of so yeah a lot of this stuff
is real i've been talking about this for
years people have been looking at me
like you're crazy i'm like they're going
into your behinds watch your behinds for
years i'm like oh you're kidding
you're just i'm like i'm not joking i'm
telling you this is coming
and this little thing with the diplomats
is only going to of course be the start
of this
since they're going to be expanding this
and and other countries are going to
recognize
everyone's dna we've got a fact check
they don't go around collecting the
president's poop
because they're scared of people
collecting it they they bring secure
portable toilets for the president for
security reasons yes
because if the president's like in a
mall bathroom or whatever it's like it's
a security risk
another risk is of course the people
getting information on the president
from the inside of the poop well well
well
look is correct from npr china wants
your dna and may
already have it yeah i saw that go by
yeah they say as covid cases begin to
rise a year ago a chinese company
contacted several u.s states and offered
to set up testing labs
as a byproduct the chinese firm beijing
genomics institute would likely gain
access to the dna of those tested
the offer was tempting for states
struggling to set their own testing
facilities for a new virus and short
notice
but u.s national security officials
urged the states to reject the offer
citing concerns about how china might
use personal data collected on americans
quote we certainly reached out to our
partners and the community to make sure
people were aware
that the chinese were pushing out these
tests informing them of what the risks
were
and really asking them not to take the
tests said mike orlando
the head of the national
counterintelligence and security center
which is part of the office
of the director of national intelligence
as far as i know they all turned them
down
so there's actually a bunch of stories
about this they've been
trying to get access to american dna
have you guys ever used those uh
23andme tests yeah it's the same idea
i've never taken them have you guys
have you taken them before no my brother
did recently though so i guess all my
dna is out you're in
yeah i just don't i don't know if it's a
big deal but i don't want to
speed up the process if it might be so i
just haven't no it's a huge
deal this is crazy from newsweek china
wants your dna and it's up to no good
from gordon ji
chang an author this is from november of
2020 and he says
why does china want such sensitive data
beijing is determined to dominate the
biotech industry
beijing may also be developing
biological weapons designed to target
certain ethnic groups yep i had that
i had that in my list i was waiting to
talk about that because again
we have to understand it's not just the
pharma industrial complex that's going
to be screwed over if china gets all of
our dna
that's going to outbid them and know
what people are going to be sick of and
know what the demand is in the big
pharma markets but it's also
bio weapons that of course could be used
could be genetically engineered
to specifically go after individuals
with a specific genotype
and only affect them so this is larger
biological warfare stuff that of course
is
is being studied being conducted a lot
of it the united states is paying for
but a lot of it is ending up in the
hands of the chinese which is absolutely
perplexing mind-boggling and
infuriating to find out i mean dr fauci
was literally responsible
and and was one of the bigger founders
behind that level three
level wuhan laboratory inside of china
not many people want to talk about this
but they were doing gain of function
data studies on the coronaviruses linked
to bats specifically
talking about how they can engineer them
again not trying to come up with any
theories here i'm just stating some
facts that were
talked about by the us mainstream media
and admitted to them i'm not jumping to
any conclusions
but it's an important fact to understand
here that this did happen i mean new
yorker had a piece
that explored this concept right and i
think one of the things that we probably
don't give china enough credit for
is they are evaluating different ways of
fighting asymmetric warfare
of thinking about ways that they can get
a jump on the united states and that's
everything from building new battleships
to exploring the ways that they they can
use biological weapons and exploring the
rectums of these
difficulties speaking of exploring yeah
and i'm tim i'm also with you i think on
your earlier point
because i think some of this is just a
power game right yeah i'm i'm reminded
of how
uh during during the cold war the u.s
state department this is back when we
were tough and good at things i think
a long long time ago in u.s foreign
policy the
uh the russia desk would only hire
diplomats
from the united states who were men who
were over six feet
because they wanted to make sure that
there was a better chance that they
would be able to
physically look down on their russian
counterparts wow
psychologically so much of it is i mean
think about it like it's it's just
a giant game of chess at least to the
state as far as the state department
sees the world
so much of it is just a big chess game
and so why not have every advantage
but think about this too like china has
no shame they want to win
and they'll do whatever it takes exactly
even looking in the butts of our
diplomats
and i know it's funny but this is
serious too because we wouldn't do that
for the most part
the united states probably isn't even
thinking about having someone open up
you know spread their cheeks and then
take a sample but china knows there's
things we'll learn and secrets will gain
access to by understanding the diets
the the gut biomes of these people right
and if they can produce some
look we know that like gut bacteria is
very important
what if they're thinking can we craft
something that just is a detriment to
american diet gut bacteria and that
causes americans to become
bloated and tired it's a hypothetical
but seriously there's a lot you can
learn from that sickle cell anemia
notoriously was harming the
african-american population
for whatever reason it's it's not a it's
not a fecal it's not like a bacterial
disease it's a blood disease it might be
it's
genetic yeah so so it's part of the i
think it's part of the blood cell it's
part of the shape of the
african-american blood cell and it is
different
it's based on the genome and i was
actually talking i've talked to people
who have advanced scientific degrees
this is one of those conversations you
can't have but they did tell me you can
design
things that only attack certain genomes
they only attack certain races
this is something china has thought
about americans don't think about it
chinese think about everything
we thought about our kids with tick tock
they're thinking about bio weapons
maybe possibly with covet i don't know
we're not conspiring here but
well the us has been talking about bio
weapons especially with some classified
documentation that came out for
for you know a very long time ever since
the vietnam war
uh now as far as how clandestine and how
overt they are we don't know
because a lot of it is clandestine a lot
of it is something that we don't know
there's no transparency there's no
accountability
whether on china they just do everything
out in the open
but also with you know you have to
understand you could get someone's dna
from a no swap you could also get it
from a behind swab
not a swab probe you could get it from a
butt probe as well so
they most likely now the chinese have a
whole bunch of dna samples on all the us
diplomats that willingly
took their pants off when the chinese
government said take them off and they
did
which is which is i mean just imagine
being a us diplomat and
and just saying yeah sure china here
instead of being like i'll get on a
plane and leave right
yeah right instead of having some like
dignity and saying hey no
no you're not sticking anything off my
butt
like i'm sorry like like like have some
courage here
the u.s department has to release trust
to the science
that's what it's all about you got to
trust science are you saying you hate
science
yeah um so science is a big hammer and
if you use it improperly you can do a
lot of harm with it
yeah this is gross it is stuff
do you think i want to get into
symmetrical warfare not going to
interview with one of these diplomats
and just hear it from their own mouths
they'll be like rocking back and forth
yeah
they don't make water hot enough yeah
and that's the thing too like hands are
cold
at what point would they just kind of
look to their supervisor superior and be
like dude do we have to do this
like like at one point with somebody
just like you know actually i'm we're
gonna call back to the embassy we're
gonna check on this one real quick
give us five minutes what is it like for
us diplomats are they like under the the
finger of the communist party when
they're over there that's a good
question
probably not i i would assume not only
because they spend so much time on
american properties right on embassies
and consulates
the interesting thing though this is
something i could have expected from the
american media
because they very much live under the
thumb of of beijing while they're over
there
but you would think that the american
diplomatic core would have a little bit
more
a little bit more dignity a little bit
more self-esteem and a little bit more
of an ability to push back and say no no
we're not going to do this but listen
we're living in strange times and so
america's becoming weak
yes we can it's it's a big metaphor here
it's easy for biden to be like i'm going
to bomb syria because what's syria going
to do about it
and we go up against russia because
russia could fight back to a certain
degree but ultimately
what are they going to do about it china
oh yeah we can't fight china they'll win
and they're winning that's the that's
the scary reality of everything that's
going on and i think so much of it is
they want to see like and this this to
me
more than anything else is they want to
see what they can get away with right
this is
in so many ways this is just a microcosm
of the sorts of things that they're
doing in the south china sea the sorts
of things they're doing in tibet
the sorts of things that they're doing
investing in africa and eastern europe
um this is this is a power play right so
much of this is a power play and it's
how far can we push the big guy on the
block the united states
and get away with doing this kind of
stuff and if we can keep doing this
right if we can if the belt and road
program can run through traditional us
allies across
africa if we can muscle our way into
tibet
if we can muscle our way into hong kong
why
can't we do some uh rear-end swabs on
u.s diplomats why isn't that the next
step
it's it's it's incremental it it sounds
silly to a lot of people they probably
don't think it's that big of a deal but
it's just one more grain of sand making
a bigger heap where china says we can do
whatever we want we can go to an
american and say take off your pants and
bend over right now and they'll go yes
sir
yes no problem sir i when i first heard
it i think yesterday maybe you brought
it up yeah i just know
i was bringing it up yesterday i heard
about it i was looking at the sources
like we need to confirm this yeah
as we were talking about this a few
weeks ago a few weeks ago we were saying
hey china has developed a new way to
test for covid and it's going up your
buttocks three inches
to swab you and i'm like this is not
what you think it is it's coming uh
it's going to be expanded and now here
we are today sorry
it almost like washed over me yesterday
i was just like oh well
whatever i'm not surprised but
they lied about it they lied they lied
about it big time that's really a big
deal man this is bad
no it's it's it's it's a decay it's just
like everything seems to be
heading down into the into the into the
crapper yeah
literally and figured yeah that's right
yeah and well
yeah i was gonna say and so much of this
too is it's
it's china stepping back and not just
pushing to see where they can go but
to forgive the pun but probing where the
weaknesses are
right where are the vulnerabilities
where are the places where u.s diplomats
aren't
don't have a levelhead about them in
terms of the decisions they're going to
make the power that they're gonna that
they're gonna stand up against and the
things that they're unwilling to do
and i think before they do that thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you